hot breath i skyrocketed off of a viral
video
and for me
i did the work afterwards and i wrote
material and i
toured and i hustled but getting to that
like
break i know there's so many comics who
went through
years and years of you know mc
feature like driving their car six hours
just to get
a 15 minute spot and then when they get
there they bomb but then they still
drive six hours to the next one and like
you know people like really paid some
dues
to get to where i was starting
so i knew that my dues looked
differently and it was kind of like
when i got to where i was that's when
the work ethic came in
because sometimes if you hit success too
soon you don't have the character to
sustain it
you don't have the work ethic to sustain
it but for me
i i had those things i had a good head
on my shoulders
i had my intentions right i had
work ethic i had character i had faith
i had um all of those things that
sustained where i was and i had my eye
on the prize i had goals i wasn't
swayed by like party over here or let's
just get wasted and then
wake up late for a press the next
morning or whatever like
i was very responsible with this gift
that i had been
given and made sure that i stewarded it
well
so that i could continue to grow and and
earn
things from there you know sounds like
you're very organized
i mean sure yeah
you said you have goals a lot of times
comics are like well i'll just do this
six hour gig for 50 bucks because that's
what we got to do but it seems like with
the internet
and you're an example of that we can
create our own success
with the right intention behind it yeah
yeah yeah
intention um eye on the prize like
bigger picture
understanding like maybe you you put all
this work into creating this video
and it doesn't go viral that doesn't
mean give
up that just means make a few more
because when somebody sees that and goes
oh that's kind of funny i wonder if they
have anything else and they look for
something else
like well that's kind of funny too and
then i'm gonna follow them on instagram
just
and see and then like a couple months
later you show up in their feed
and then here's your other video that
you just made that is funnier than the
other ones and now they're like oh my
god i'm going to send this one to all my
friends
but if you were like oh see i put all
this work into this video
it didn't even go viral only got like 30
views on it like people don't like it
like
you you keep creating because you are a
creative person
and you put your creative art out there
and then if people respond to it they
respond to it it's really like
that's not your business what they
respond to if you're creating
as a creative person when you put your
authentic self
out there hopefully people respond to
like oh that's good
but the second you start creating to
impress them
to get their validation to get their
view everybody's different you're not
for everybody so then you're gonna get
insecure like
it didn't work like i was trying to be
what they wanted me to be and it didn't
work well nobody wants you to be
they want you to be you like show up and
be you when i first started stand up
i was trying to pretend i was super
mexican and i would
all my early jokes when i talk about my
mom and my dad they have an accent
and they're very like i mean you threw
the ball over there and like all this
stuff
my mom does not speak spanish at all my
dad does not speak spanish i'm fourth
generation mexican
and it wasn't until i started like
owning them i still have people that
their favorite jokes of mine
is the one where um it's one of my first
jokes
and i'm talking about my mom and dad and
their very spanish accent and
how i spank everybody's kids because
that's how mexican people do it and
i still have people are like oh my god
that's like my favorite joke and i was
like wow that's like my first one when i
wasn't even being true to myself but
thank you i'm glad you responded to it
and liked it
because i knew it was funny it made
people laugh it just wasn't
me but when i started owning me
and being just me not who i thought they
wanted me to be but owning
i don't speak spanish let me write a
joke about how i don't speak spanish
instead of pretending
that i speak spanish and hope they don't
catch me so when i started owning that
and being true to who i am people
respond to authenticity
people respond to that truth and so
that's when i really started to see like
more growth high breath